IN SIX DAYS, VOTERS HEAD TO THE
POLLS TO DECIDE WHO WILL CONTROL
CONGRESS AND THE CRITICAL
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP KICKS OFF HIS
FINAL CAMPAIGN BLITZ IN FLORIDA.
BERNIE SANDERS WILL ALSO BE
HOLDING A DUELING RALLY.
THE PRESIDENT CONFIDENT ABOUT
REPUBLICANS CHANCES ON TUESDAY.
>> IT SEEMS THAT THE CAMPAIGN IS
GOING VERY WELL.
LOOKS LIKE WE ARE DOING VERY,
VERY WELL IN THE SENATE.
A LOT OF SEATS THAT WERE NOT
REALLY BEING THOUGHT OF IN TERMS
OF VICTORIES A YEAR AGO NOW ARE
LOOKING LIKE THEY COULD VERY
WELL BE VICTORIES.
THE HOUSES A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THEY WERE GOING TO DO WELL IN
THE HOUSE ALSO.
I KNOW WE ARE DOING WELL IN THE
SENATE AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE ARE
DOING OKAY IN THE HOUSE.
>> Jesse: TRUMP ALSO ISSUING A
NEW WARNING ABOUT WHAT WILL
HAPPEN IF DEMOCRATS TAKE THE
HOUSE.
SPEAK WITH HIM AND TERMS FOR
SOME REASON DON'T DO SO WELL FOR
REPUBLICANS, I THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO LOSE A LOT OF MONEY.
I HATE TO SAY THAT.
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO LOSE A
LOT OF MONEY.
PEOPLE ARE WAITING ON THEIR
401(K)s AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
THEY ARE WAITING TO DO WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE MIDTERMS.
>> Jesse: NANCY PELOSI ALREADY
TAKING A VICTORY LAP, PREDICT --
PREDICTING HER PARTY HAS THE --
>> I PREDICT WE WOULD WIN.
NOW I AM SAYING WE WILL WIN.
WE WILL WIN.
>> DO YOU WANT TO SAY THAT ON
HILLARY'S FIREWORKS BARGE?
PLEASE DON'T SAY THAT.
>> WE OWN THE GROUND.
WE ARE NOT YIELDING ONE GRAIN OF
SAND.
>> Jesse: WOW.
SHE GUARANTEED VICTORY IN 2016
TOO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT HER
PREDICTION?
>> Judge Jeanine: I DON'T
THINK MUCH OF PELOSI.
THEY USE HOLLYWOOD CELEBRITIES
ALL THE TIME.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
HILLARY THOUGHT SHE WAS A
CELEBRITY.
THE PRESIDENT WENT OUT AND
CAMPAIGN FOR HILLARY.
IN THE END, IT DIDN'T MATTER.
BARBRA STREISAND SAID SHE WAS
MOVING TO CANADA.
NOW SHE'S THREATENING TO MOVE TO
CANADA AGAIN.
THEY ALWAYS SAY THAT.
IN THE END, THE REPUBLICANS CARE
ABOUT THEIR MONEY.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
I THINK THERE'S A LITTLE TROUBLE
IN THE HOUSE.
>> Jesse: SOUNDED LIKE THE
PRESIDENT WASN'T AS CONFIDENT IN
THE HOUSE AS HE WAS IN THE
SENATE, GREG.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE ABOUT THE TONE?
>> Greg: IF BARBRA STREISAND
MOVES TO CANADA, I HEAR CANADA
IS MOVING TO NEW ZEALAND.
HERE'S WHAT I THINK.
BOTH SIDES ARE DOING THE SAME
THING RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE RAILING AT THE BASE.
THEY LARK MOTIVATIONAL SPEAKERS
WHO TELL YOU THE WORST
POSSIBLE SCENARIO.
DON'T DO THAT TO ME.
IF TRUMP WINS MACK, THE LEFT
SAYS GRANNY WILL BE PUSHED OFF A
CLIFF AND THEY WILL TAKE HER
SOCIAL SECURITY.
WHITE MEN ARE GOING TO PUT
LITTLE BOYS IN CAGES.
BUT IF TRUMP WINS, ALL CARAVANS
ARE WELCOME IN ENGLISH WILL BE
THERE AND IN HIGH SCHOOL.
THE REALITY IS ACTUALLY TRUE.
CREATING A BROAD ASSUMPTION
BASED ON STEREOTYPES AND THEY
ARE BOTH DOING IT.
THEY ARE BOTH GUILTY.
>> Jesse: TRUMP'S TACTIC COULD
BE MORE TRUE THAN THE OTHER
SCARE TACTICS.
THE ECONOMY, JUAN.
WAGE GROWTH HIGHEST IN A DECADE.
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE HIGHEST
SINCE 1998.
SOMEONE VERY SMART ON
NEIL CAVUTO'S SHOW SAID IN 1988
WAS THE LAST TIME CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE WAS THIS HIGH AND
BILL CLINTON'S PARTY DID VERY
WELL IN THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
HOW DO YOU SEE THE ECONOMY
PLAYING IN THIS YEARS MIDTERMS?
>> Juan: I THINK IT'S OBVIOUS.
THE REPUBLICANS CAN'T RUN ON IT
THAT'S WHY THE PRESIDENT HAS TO
RESORT TO FEAR AND LOATHING IN
FRIGHT NIGHT EARLY.
SENDING TROOPS TO THE BORDER.
GANGSTERS, MS-13, DISEASES
APPROACHING THE BORDER AND I'M
SENDING TROOPS.
WHAT KIND OF MADNESS IS IT?
GREG IS RIGHT.
A LOT OF THINGS ARE BEING SAID
THAT JUST AREN'T TRUE.
>> Greg: I SAID BOTH SIDES.
I WAS BEING FAIR.
>> Juan: YEAH, BUT I'M NOT
BEING FAIR.
>> Greg: OH!
>> Juan: THERE IS NO ANALOGOUS
ACTION BY THE DEMOCRATS.
WHAT YOU HAVE IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP --
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS SAY
THERE'S GOING TO BE A CIVIL WAR
AND HITLER AND HE'S GOING TO
LOCK UP --
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK
DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING A CIVIL WA
CIVIL WAR.
>> Greg: BLOOD ON THE STREETS.
TAKING SOCIAL SECURITY.
>> Juan: I THINK THEY ARE MORE
OF SET ABOUT TRUMP.
>> Jedidiah: DEMOCRATS ARE
ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT HEALTH CARE
IS THE CHIEF ISSUE.
EVERYONE'S HEALTH CARE IS GOING
TO BE TAKEN AWAY.
WHAT ARE WE EVEN TALKING ABOUT?
>> Juan: ISN'T IT TRUE THAT
REPUBLICANS PROMISE THAT ONCE
THEY TOOK OVER, THEY WOULD
REPEAL AND REPLACE.
>> Jedidiah: YOU ARE SAYING
THAT'S NOT A SCARE TACTIC?
>> Juan: THAT'S WHAT
REPUBLICAN SAVIOR REPUBLICANS
HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING AND ONLY
BELATEDLY NOW IS THE PRESIDENT
SAYING IF YOU HAVE PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS, I WOULD CONSIDER IT.
HE IS LATE TO THE GAME.
>> Judge Jeanine: ARE YOU
KIDDING, JUAN?
THE ECONOMY, CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE.
>> Juan: WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
HEALTH CARE.
>> Judge Jeanine: HE GOT RID
OF THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHY DEMOCRATS
ARE RUNNING ADS AND WHY THEY ARE
HAVING SUCCESS BY SAYING TO
AMERICANS RIGHT NOW THAT
HEALTH CARE IS IN JEOPARDY UNDER
TRUMP.
>> Greg: WHEN THEY USE FEAR
TACTICS, THEY ARE TELLING THE
TRUTH?
BUT WHEN ANYONE ELSE --
SOCIAL SECURITY FOR ONE.
IN TALKING ABOUT HOW EVIL TRUMP
IS, HOW RACIST AND INSANE.
>> Juan: THAT'S NOT A FEAR
TACTIC.
>> Greg: I AM POINTING OUT
WHAT YOU JUST DID.
>> Jedidiah: WHY IS IT CRAZY
TO TALK ABOUT SECURING A BORDER.
IMMIGRATION --
>> Juan: JESSE AND I HAVE BEEN
OVER THIS 1,000 TIMES.
REMEMBER WHEN OBAMA, REMEMBERING
OTHER PEOPLE PUT IN ADDITIONAL
SECURITY OF THE BORDER.
>> Jedidiah: THE REASON THE
ECONOMY --
>> Jesse: OPERA HITTING THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL TOMORROW IN
GEORGIA TO STUMP FOR STACEY
ABRAMS.
TAYLOR SWIFT POSTED SHE IS
VOTING FOR DEMOCRAT PHIL
BREDESEN IN TENNESSEE AND IS
URGING FANS NOT TO SIT THIS ONE
OUT.
GREG, CELEBRITIES GETTING
INVOLVED.
OPRAH.
>> Greg: OPRAH IS DIFFERENT
THAN ALYSSA MILANO, WILL
FERRELL.
>> Jesse: SHE IS AN ICON.
I BELIEVE THE NEW --
>> Greg: IT CANCELS THE
POSITIVE IMPACT OF THEIR FAMOUS
SPACE.
YOU HAVE SOMEONE LIKE, WHEN
SOMEONE GETS INTO POLITICS AS A
CELEBRITY, THEY ARE STUNTED.
IT'S LIKE THEIR POLITICS ARE
BACK WHERE THEY WERE WHEN THEY
DECIDED TO CHASE FAME.
IT'S LIKE A 17-YEAR-OLD.
FOR TEN YEARS, THEY'VE BEEN ALL
ABOUT THEMSELVES.
FINALLY THEY FEEL GUILTY ABOUT
THIS AND THEY GO, I'M GOING TO
BECOME POLITICALLY AWARE.
BUT THEY ARE BACK WHERE THEY
WERE WHEN THEY STOPPED READING.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT'S EVEN
WORSE THAN THAT.
IT'S NOT LIKE TEN YEARS.
IT'S THE FACT, WHAT DO THEY DO
FOR A LIVING?
THEY DON'T THINK.
THEY MEMORIZE LINES OF THE
PEOPLE RIGHT.
>> Greg: OH, WELL, WE KIND OF
DO THAT TOO.
EVERYBODY HAS A RIGHT TO AN
OPINION, BUT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO ANALYZE AND SAY WHERE ARE
THEY IN THE ROAD TO LIFE?
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT DO THEY
KNOW?
WHAT'S THEIR EXPERIENCE?
WHAT IS IT BASED ON?
I'M FAMOUS SO THEREFORE BELIEVE
ME AND EVERYONE IN MY ILK.
>> Jesse: HE HAS PILES OF
NOTES.
>> Greg: I DIDN'T GET TO MY
>> Juan: A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
YOU TOLD ME KANYE WEST, HE'S
GREAT.
HE'S SO SMART.
TALK ABOUT A HALLOWING SURPRISE.
>> Greg: THAT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH HIS STANCE ON TRUMP.
>> Juan: BACK WHEN HE WAS 17 I
KNEW NOTHING.
HOW ABOUT DONALD TRUMP?
HE'S A CELEBRITY POLITICIAN.
>> Jedidiah: THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE RIGHT OF KANYE WEST TO
HAVE AN OPINION.
>> Greg: YOU ARE ATTACKING HIM
FOR OTHER REASONS, JUAN.
>> Juan: USING PROFANITY AND
REPUBLICANS LOVED IT.
>> Jesse: I WILL SAY NO ONE ON
THIS SIDE CALLED OPRAH OR ANY OF
THESE OTHER TAYLOR SWIFT PEOPLE
MENTALLY ILL.
>> Juan: KANYE SAID --
>> Jesse: NO ONE SAID A LOT OF
DISGUSTING THINGS ABOUT ANYONE
FOR ENDORSING ANYONE.
KANYE WEST SUFFERED SOME OF THE
MOST HORRIBLE RHETORIC ABOUT
ANYONE ON TELEVISION, BESIDES
ME.
HE DIDN'T DESERVE IT.
THAT CAME FROM YOUR SIDE.